plus de trois mois que l'on n'avait pas
vu ces images des kite surfer sur le
plan d'eau de lance michel à sainte anne
depuis mai la plage était fermé à cause
des sargasses on a la chance d'avoir à
des personnes qui déblaient un peu les
plages et enlève les algues donc la
plage et pas trop la trouille inondées
on est plutôt content le site est à
nouveau ouvert à la baignade
même si les algues sont toujours
présentes mais la brigade verte de
sainte-anne veille au grain sa nouvelle
aubaine parce que la levée de fonds
propres élevé josiane et la poisse
gargati de la quantité à guimiliau et
même pendant la journée on doit
travailler de nouvelles de mathieu c'est
le pays où nous avons aussi bloqué il
gagne en plus contre il est saoul et les
commerces sur place sont pour l'instant
fermé et à par aude des vacanciers ne
s'arrête pas qu'ils sont tous entraînés
nettoyer la plage donc fait que cet
après-midi ce sera fini je sais pas vous
allez attendre pour prendre le biais de
m quelqu'un peut et ensuite j'avais je
vais rentrer à lens on voit le spectacle
est différent
place à la désolation là impossible de
se baigner
l'odeur d'hydrogène sulfuré est bien
présente
les services de la mairie sont à pied
d'oeuvre c'est une catastrophe
au cap chevalier la situation a évolué
il n'y a plus de sargasses les
professionnels il c'est de relancer
l'activité
mais ils se sentent quelque peu
abandonné pour eux le mal est déjà fait
les clients ont déserté les lieux
on y voit deux activités si c'est le
calme plat
d'accord ça fait depuis le mois de mars
et là effectivement ça va diminuer on
espère que pour la fin des vacances ont
redémarré nous sommes abandonnés parce
que
la qui a plus dingue maintenant qui a pu
die
on n'a plus personne de venir vers nous
donc on a déjà plus de clients mais au
niveau de l'état ou encore de ce qui
aurait pu nous aider on y sommes et
villemur a déjà le restaurant dont
souffrent et pour elle aussi les
affaires sont au point mort décidé
d'ouvrir un petit peu après le tour des
yoles toute la semaine c'est que le week
end voir si ça va bouger entre le mois
de mars et a aujourd'hui on a perdu déjà
au moins cinquante mille euros
je me dis cette semaine s'il se produit
pas quelque chose ou bien le mois se
termine septembre on pourra plus être là
comme une roulette russe la plaisance de
sargasses sur les plages est tellement
aléatoire que ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui ne l'est pas obligatoirement
demain